[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
July 12th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
many Americans spend their retirement
years regretting not planning better and
it's not just about saving money Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Veronica dagger joins us so Veronica it
seems like there are many resources
focused on planning for retirement we
talk about it often on this show so why
is it so hard for people to map out a
plan well partly because you've never
done it before most people have never
had this trial run or practice to
retirement and so when they turn in
their ID and then the next Monday comes
along they don't know what to do with
themselves it's a tough transition
especially if you don't have that kind
of preparation and so you find out
things cost more than you expected in
retirement you wish you had maybe spent
more time building relationships to last
outside of the office and keeping up
with the ones in the office and just
taking better care of your health and
cultivating new interests now you spoke
with several retirees about their
experience and their planning and what
they wish they had done better what was
the common theme couple common themes
one big one is that invest testing for
retirement isn't just about money so
often we hear oh have that financial
plan make sure it lasts till you're 100
or whatever the financial planners are
saying these days about longevity but
there's other aspects to this that you
can't quantify so figuring out what will
motivate you in retirement so if you're
a very driven person you need to figure
out how you're going to fill out your
time whether it's a new interest whether
it's studying people forget that so much
of their self-worth their sense of
achievement accomplishment is all
connected to their job very often and so
when your job ends you might be sitting
around saying wait who am I what's the
meaning of my life what am I doing here
and so cultivating some of those
interests those Hobbies those passions
while you're still working can help set
you up for retirement that is happier
and more fulfilling yeah you don't hear
people talk about very often the fact
that your persona stays with you that
doesn't go away when you retire it
doesn't go away but how people relate to
you often uh goes away for example if
you were an executive maybe you're not
CEO but you were an executive and you
don't have a hundred reports checking in
with you and giving you a sense of
meaning or a sense of accomplishment
every day you're not making all these
thousand decisions every day you might
find yourself floundering but yes you as
a core person that doesn't change and it
actually never had anything to do with
your job now you mentioned relationships
a moment ago why are relationships
important to retirement it's interesting
the biggest predictor of longevity
health and happiness in later life is
the quality of your relationships and
that's a finding from the Harvard study
of adult development which has followed
families for decades I spoke to a
gentleman who had retired about 18
months ago and he was just so happy to
be walking out the door saying you know
I'm never going back to working again
but he didn't Factor something really
important into his equation soon after
he retired his son and his family who
used to live two hours away moved all
the way to New Zealand and as we know
that's a very expensive and far flight
well him and his wife had only budgeted
a small amount for travel every year and
so now because he hadn't kept up his
relationships at work he hadn't kept up
his professional licenses
he feels like the door to contract work
and Consulting is no longer there he
also feels that if he had kept those
doors open he'd get to see his
grandchildren more often because he'd be
able to afford to go to New Zealand many
more times a year so you got to think
about your long-term plan may end up
being different than you expect you may
need more money than you expect you may
need to find ways to connect with your
family and that could cost you money
especially if they move away in this day
and age so people as they get into their
60s might think oh boy it's time to
retire when they look at the societal
norms and what Society has said about
when retirement should come around but
maybe they should look past that right
because just because you can take Social
Security benefits anytime between age 62
and 70 doesn't mean you have to do that
because if you're going to wait to take
Social Security you're going to get more
money for every month of delay for many
the math favors starting at age 70 when
the monthly benefits before cost of
living adjustments are 76 percent higher
than at 62 and that's according to a
Boston University Economist so what's
the message here for people who still
have years or maybe even decades to go
before they hit retirement so find out
your passion and cultivate those
interests cultivate those relationships
also realize that retirement could be a
lot longer than you think yeah we see
photos of retirees and everyone looks
really happy playing shuffleboard or
playing golf or hanging out with the
grandkids right not everyone has
grandkids not everyone wants to hang out
with the grandkids if they
not everyone wants to golf or play
shuffleboard maybe they want to go
dancing maybe they want nothing to do
with their family or maybe they want to
completely travel the world or live in
an RV so there's no cookie cutter
picture of what retirement looks like
and I think that's one of the reasons
retirement is so hard to prepare for is
that we often lack models of this
post-work life to emulate that's Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Veronica dagger and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
foreign